política y drogas Genaro García Luna El
poderoso ex secretario de seguridad del
gobierno mexicano de Felipe Calderón
está a punto de ser juzgado luego de ser
acusado de ayudar al Cartel De Sinaloa a
contrabandear 53 toneladas de cocaína a
Estados Unidos la periodista peli
Ramírez investigó el caso durante 10
años y escribió un libro sobre su
importancia este juicio contra García
Luna es importante porque es el juicio
más relevante que ha derivado hasta
ahora del juicio al Chapo Guzmán va a
ser presidido por el mismo juez en la
misma corte y va a estar protagonizado
por una persona que era al mismo tiempo
un alto funcionario en México y un gran
Aliado de el gobierno de Estados Unidos
durante el juicio del Chapo en 2019 un
ex miembro de su cartel afirmó que le
dio a García maletas llenas de dinero en
efectivo en distintas oportunidades
García Luna fue detenido ese mismo año
en Dallas y según la fiscalía
estadounidense el funcionario habría
utilizado su cargo para pasar por alto
el control de drogas manejadas por el
Chapo Guzmán Entre 2001 y 2012 en 2020
García Luna Se declaró inocente y desde
este 17 de enero se enfrenta un juicio
que podría sentenciarlo desde los 10
años de prisión hasta la cadena perpetua
era el segundo hombre más poderoso
después del presidente
en temas de seguridad y bueno ahora está
acusado de haber sido al mismo tiempo un
funcionario para el gobierno mexicano de
alto Rango un gran Aliado de la DEA la
agencia antinarcóticos de Estados Unidos
en México y uno de los principales
aliados de Joaquín El Chapo Guzmán y el
cártel de Sinaloa la defensa adelantado
que cuenta con múltiples pruebas y
testigos y defenderá que García estaba
colaborando con la DEA para dar
información sobre los